I believe that our country uniquely for
the time was founded on mistrust for the
government which is which is such a
heavy and beautiful idea you know the
idea that we have all the rights in the
world we have complete and utter freedom
and we give up very specific freedoms in
order to have a government that will
protect the other freedoms ah such a
profound idea and so deep and so
wonderful and I think that it was so
weird to see all the people who said
that dissent was part of their job
during the Bush administration turn
around and say that we were all supposed
to rally behind Obama I mean I I
disagreed Bush and Obama tremendously
and I'm the exact same issues I mean and
the only issue that really matters to me
is his Wars and killing people overseas
I don't get them and I was against of
what Bush was doing it and now that
Obama is doing it more I'm against it
too and I think that it's part of the of
the joy and the Wonder and the
brilliance of the ideas of the United
States of America that whoever is in
power his question and beat up I was
asked in I'm going on The Joy Behar show
later today and you get questions ahead
of time unlike here they lay stuff on
the head of time and it was Obama said
he wants to figure out whose ass to kick
and that before he was busted for being
not emotional enough to cold and now
he's being busted for being too straight
how can he win and my answer is he's not
supposed to win he's the president
they're supposed to be millions of
people disagreeing with him on
everything and busting him on everything
that's the way the country is supposed
to work and that's not something to be
to bemoan the fact that the government
can't rally everybody to work together
that's to be celebrated the government
being is hamstrung and as as as closed
off and as clumsy as possible is exactly
what we want the last thing we want is a
government that can get things done a
government that can get things done all
they will get done is taking away
freedoms it's been shown over and over
again we want a clunky sloppy
slow-moving small insignificant weak
government there all the time and that's
the government we can love and protect
it's the same misconception that
everybody seems to have about everyone
else
and it's the same misconception
libertarians have about liberals or
conservatives have and that is we
sometimes tend to forget that
everybody's trying for the best that
everyone's goals are the same with very
small differences I mean the goal of a
socialist and the goal of a libertarian
are exactly the same
the goals are happiness and security and
freedom and you balance those but I
think the biggest misconception that I
find about libertarians is that there's
a there's a lack of compassion and I
think that there is there is as much
compassion among libertarians as there
is among liberals it's not it's not what
the problems are it's it's how to solve
them everybody wants clean safe energy
some people think nuclear is the way to
go some people think coals the way to go
some people think winds the way to go
and there's always balances on that
libertarians tend to put freedom as a
goal in itself and also a way to attain
other groups liberals tend to put
security as a goal in itself and a way
to obtain other goals I think the
biggest misconception is that
libertarians I guess the cliche would be
don't care about the crack babies I just
think you can deal with people in
trouble using compassion one of the
things that bothers me about statism is
that they they take away my compassion
when you take money from me by force run
it through the government to help other
people I think there's less compared
than me being able to do something what
I say about libertarians versus liberals
is I will gladly help you build the
library I will not use a gun to get
someone else to join us in helping to
build that library I want credit you
know I want credit for helping I want to
feel like I'm helping and giving money
to government does not seem like the
best way to help and forcing other
people to give money to the government
seems immoral to me I think that if I
want to cure cancer I should work on
curing cancer
you can't force other people to give
money to cure kids there then you're not
really helping or you're helping in a
way they don't think is right so the the
question on health care was not if you
saw someone lying in the street who
needed help would you run over and
bandage them the question is really if
you saw someone suffering in the street
would you run get a policeman have that
policeman find a doctor have that doctor
forced by everybody around to take a
vote and then come in and help I think
but I think that it's forgotten that
what everybody's trying to do is help
the people that need it
everybody's trying that and I will say I
will say that about every political
group and I think that I would love to
see people using the word wrong more and
using the word evil less Obama is a
really good guy a really smart guy and
every moment every second of every day
is spent trying to do what's best I
disagree with him but there's no sense
that he's evil and this is something
I'll say that a lot of people will freak
out at I think the same was true for
George W Bush I think every second he
was trying as hard as he could to do
what was best I disagree with him very
very intently but that's back to the
fundamentalist atheist thing
to be able to say you're wrong and here
are the reasons is respect to say you're
evil is anti human because the people
that I've met in my life were truly bad
and are truly evil is such a small
number I mean if you take the six
billion people on the planet and round
off the numbers about six billion or
good